- Oh, those shoes are great.
- Oh, thanks!
- So wait, this is cool that
you're actually put out,
is it your own type of violin?
- Yes.
- So wait, what makes
your violin different?
- Well, so through the years
I've learned things I like
and now at this point I
customize all my violins
because classical violins
are very hard to tune.
And especially if you're in
the middle of a show or a concert-
- So you tune, like
while you're in a show?
- Yeah, the pegs will slip
and it's really hard to get.
So I've made these violins
that have these special pegs
on them that allow you to very
quickly adjust in a second.
I also put some custom
artwork that I actually drew
and it's etched into the violin,
I'm great at stick figures, so this-
- Oh, that's actually really cool.
- That's the, well
that's the original one,
but it's much cuter on the violin.
It's like gold and nice, but yeah,
- I love that
- It's just a really special piece
and it's a beautiful sounding violin.
So I was really happy, and I
was so excited our first round,
you know, sold out immediately
and we just barely got a new round in.
So I'm excited about that.
- That's great!
- Yeah.
- That's awesome, and think of all the,
like kids you're inspiring,
especially to start playing
violin, that's so cool.
Yeah, you're very powerful in that sense,
that's really cool.
- Thank you.
I have a question and
this is, I just need to
know this answer.
- Okay.
- Okay. So Shelton and I on
The Voice have often argued
the difference between
a fiddle and a violin.
So what do you think the difference
between a fiddle and a violin is?
- It's the way it's played.
- Totally.
- Yeah.
- So we're gonna edit this out to where-
(Lindsey laughs)
to where,
- [Lindsey] I was gonna
say I have a feeling
that Blake would know that-
- Here's the thing: No, but I feel like
they also use different strings.
Don't fiddle players usually
like, is it steel strings?
Or like, I feel like they use different,
I thought I was gonna be
right on this, so I asked,
- [Audience Member] It's a good question.
- It's a great, I get that
asked that all the time
but like sometimes I'll play
fiddle music and sometimes-
- [Kelly] It's how you play it.
- It's how you play.
- [Kelly] So you're saying he was right.
It's fine.
- I'm sorry, Kelly.
- We're gonna edit this out.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] I'm just
kidding, I'll keep it in.
No, you also run a nonprofit,
this is really cool.
Cause I love when people do so well
that you help others as well.
So this is called The Upside Fund?
- Yes.
- What is it about, what
do you do with that?
- So just because my
own personal experience
I've lost several people that were some
of the closest people in my life
my best friend and my dad
both passed away from cancer.
And I experience firsthand
so much time in the hospital
seeing how it's run, seeing
how medical bills pile up.
And most people sometimes get
trapped under these forever.
And, and especially in my
case, we lost those people.
And so I started The Upside
Fund to help families going
through medical crisis and
help pay those medical bills.
And it's something that I've been doing,
it started as just like a
Christmas giveaway one year,
I was like, email me if you know
someone that's going through it,
and I made a separate
email and I got thousands
of emails and people that
couldn't pay their medical bills.
And it made me realize
there is such a need here.
And so I, I turned it
into official fund and
- [Kelly] Yeah
you know, I've been doing
it for four years now.
- [Kelly] Honestly,
that's the coolest thing.
You're so talented, you do so many things.
It's the coolest thing
you're doing to though
because I have this talk,
argument with people all the time
because I feel like it's very hard,
like cuz I'm from a poor background
and it's very hard for
poor people to stay well.
Like cuz it's so expensive.
The medical field it's
so expensive and yes,
all the advances are wonderful
and what we can do for people.
But I feel like sometimes
it's only available
for people that can afford it.
And it's, and it's really
cool that you're doing that
because people sometimes don't
take their family members
in cuz they know they're,
they're gonna get stuck with,
I'm talking hundreds of thousands
of dollars and it's, nobody can,
nobody is ever gonna be
able to pay that off.
So that's so cool that you're doing that.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] I can only imagine
the families that you're helping.
It's a really cool thing.
I know that you love helping others.
And we have a girl here who
wants to be just like you
and I know you you've
seen her right? Karolina?
- I have.
- [Kelly] Okay, Karolina's
videos are amazing,
I cannot wait for her to meet you.
I'm very excited about this moment.
So Karolina has no idea Lindsey's here.
In fact, she thinks she's
on the show just to perform
one of Lindsey's songs, which we would've
had her just do that as well.
But this is cooler.
So Lindsay's gonna go hide,
and when we come back, we're
gonna surprise her big time.
And I hope she's not so nervous.
We are back!
And at 13 years old, our
next guest is a violin
virtuoso with big dreams,
and she's working hard
to achieve them, busking weekly
here in Los Angeles and creating
a YouTube channel. Her
videos have been viewed,
this is a real number people,
more than 2 billion times.
She's gonna perform in just a minute.
But first let's meet Karolina Protsenko!
Thank you so much for coming Karolina.
- Thank you for having me,
it's an honor to be here.
- Oh my god, you're so gifted.
How did you get into the violin?
Did you want, was that
like right off the bat?
- I was born in a musical family,
- [Kelly] Oh!
- all the time I was
surrounded with music.
My mom plays piano and
she sings beautifully.
My dad plays guitar.
And when I was six years old
I really wanted to play an instrument.
- Yeah.
- So my parents asked me
do you wanna play saxophone or violin?
And I chose violin.
And you know, when you're six years old
you don't think why you're choosing it.
You like it and you start playing it.
(Audience affectionately sighs)
So yeah, I started practicing every day
and it became my passion.
And I learned more than
250 songs on violin by ear.
- Wow. By ear, that's amazing!
- Yes. I don't use music
sheets and every week
I learn two more songs to perform.
- Wow. That's incredible.
You also should do like voice-over work.
Your voice is so cute and beautiful.
- Thank you so much.
- I was like, you started talking and
all of the sudden I was
watching an animated film.
You have the most beautiful voice.
So did you start, cuz
you're playing violin
but then all the sudden you
wanted to start dancing too,
so you took like dance classes as well?
- Ballet, yeah.
- That's fun. I love that you were like,
this just isn't enough, I'm gonna do more
as if it wasn't already enough,
but what's your ultimate goal?
Like musically speaking.
- I wanna travel the world with
my concerts, playing violin
and moving in costumes
and reaching more people.
Also, I wanna write my own music.
- That's amazing! Well, since you play
by ear, that, I think you'd
probably write really well.
Do you have like someone
in the industry that
you kind of look up to?
- Yes. When I was six years old
I found a video on YouTube
of Lindsey Stirling
performing, and-
- I've had her on here before.
- Really?
- Yeah, yeah. I've actually
interviewed her before
- Wow, that's awesome! But
she wasn't just playing
as many violinists, she was also dancing,
and I wasn't dancing at that time.
So I tried to take ballet
and dance to incorporate it like her.
And what I really love
about her is that every
video she has, she,
she heals someone or makes someone happy.
That's the, the thought that she brings
and the message and it
really warms my heart.
And I also went to-
- I love you.
- a concert,
- Keep going. You are making
me so happy right now.
- Thank you
- Oh my gosh. So you went to her concert?
- Yeah. My dad made me a
surprise when I was eight.
It was a Christmas concert.
I even made her a Christmas card.
And at the end of the song,
me and my dad were running
up to the stage to give her the card.
But the guards stopped us!
They stopped us and they said
we couldn't give her the card
because we didn't have VIP tickets.
And I was very discouraged,
but my mom said
you can keep the card
and maybe one day you'll
you meet her and you'll give it to her.
So the card is very special to me.
- Well out of those 2 billion views,
she's gotta be one of 'em, right?
Like I'm like if, if
y'all do some more things,
but we do have someone here
cuz we heard about your card.
So we have someone here
that does know Lindsay
that can get the card to her.
So you might be familiar with her,
she also plays violin and
she's a YouTube sensation.
She also has five hit albums.
She is what we call a whole lotta woman.
(funky music)
I love your face right
now. You're like, what?
I'm just gonna say it:
it's Lindsey Stirling!
Get out here!
(upbeat music)
- [Lindsey] Hi! It's so nice to meet you!
- [Karolina] I, I can't believe it's you!
- [Kelly] Have a seat, have a seat!
- Yeah, have a seat!
- First of all? I love
that you both look like two little fairies
frolicking in the forest, you're so cute.
Oh my God, there's a
movie in here somewhere.
Okay. So wait, so meet Karolina.
You said that you've seen some
of her videos though, right?
- I have seen so many of your videos
and I have to say my favorite thing
about watching your videos is you sparkle.
You literally, even just
sitting here, you sparkle
your personality shines through
so much through your performances.
- Thank you
And so I was like this
girl's got something special.
And I wish I could say that-
(Audience applauds)
Right? I wish I could
say that you remind me
of me when I was a kid, but
you're so much more talented.
(laughter)
- Well she's just doing it younger.
- Yeah, yeah. I was not dancing
when I was playing when I was your age.
And so anyways, it's
just so nice to meet you.
- Oh me too. It's so nice to meet you.
I can't believe it.
- This, this beats, the
Christmas concert, right?
This is look, you got to meet her.
You can give her the card yourself.
- Oh, that story about the card.
I was like, oh no, I feel terrible.
- We don't have control over
what people like that do.
Just so you know.
- I do not mandate that.
- Yes.
- So wait, you, you have a
surprise for Karolina, right?
- I do. So I wanted to give you one
of my signature violins of your very own.
- Oh wow. Thank you.
- Which, which Carolina?
- Thank you so much.
- Which Carolina? Just so you know,
Blake Shelton was confused,
but this is also a fiddle,
but he was, he was confused.
But now he knows. Yep. Yep.
This is beautiful.
So this is your own brand,
right? This is your own.
- Yes. It's got really fine
tuners on the actual pegs,
make it tune easily, which you will love.
- Thank you so much.
- I love the little sparkle that matches
- A little sparkles.
- I know.
- Thank you Lindsey.
(applause)
- And I hear that you're
performing today and you know
I really want you to
be the focus and shine
but would you mind if I joined
you and played with you?
- Of course!
- (laughs) I love her!
I love you, Karolina.
Okay, so you, are you good with that?
If she plays along with you?
- Of course.
- Oh my God, I love this!